pga has had a uh
monopoly for a long time and there's
never been a second league to compete
against them like we're in the insurance
industry let me tell you
i wish you knew how much competition
we've had every freaking day that we got
to figure out a way to improve you know
uh everybody's like well you know how
about that podcast this podcast that
podcast what if this guy what if that
guy look if you have a message
we started with zero subscribers
and audiences showed up because we had
to get better if you don't get an
audience you're not interesting the
audience will say it you can try to do
whatever you want to do people can say
whatever they want to say about mr beast
or people can't say whatever they want
to say about pewdiepie or rogan
they are interesting and people want to
hear what they have to say and there's
competition
today you know how many podcasts there
is today you know how many podcasts
there's today worldwide millions 400
million podcasts today okay 100 million
it's a massive number worldwide in the
u.s i think i'm sorry in the u.s there's
four million podcasts in the u.s there's
four million podcasts you got four
million podcasts to choose from okay
three to four hundred million no no no
in the u.s the number i'm giving you
something
no u.s 400 is an accurate number in us
there's four million podcasts okay
how many podcasts do you got to choose
from oh my god like imagine how
competitive that is so pga tour is upset
because there's going to be one
other golf
competition for you i'm sorry pga
you you you know you you have now
somebody that you're competing against
so yeah if they can pull it off you know
great look what the
dana white said they know what says the
best thing when jake paul says stuff to
him you know what he says good you want
to pay him better start a league no one
is stopping her
start a league go for it if you want to
start a league and compete against us
and pay people better start a league see
how you can do it
go see how many i've tried so if liv
thinks they can do it better
and they think their method of doing
this is by cutting the big checks that
you got oil and you go get a badass guy
like greg norman
who is going to be making these calls to
them
all right see how it works out it may or
may not work out props to tiger for
saying yeah i'm not taking it
and uh he chose this position that he
chose but you cannot make this about
saudis are linked to 9 11 because when
the moment you play that card
you're messing yourself up because the
game of hypocrisy is gonna come back and
catch up to you man the game of
hypocrisy
is is not a good game to play you can
sit there and try to judge people the
moment you play the judgment game
first thing that happens is if somebody
like you know how they said well you do
you realize what you did when you were
you did this and you did that you did
this all the person has to say i'm sorry
for everybody watching if you ever went
to high school with this guy or college
with this guy can you please email us
whatever you have on this guy are you
okay with that mr mr reporter well no no
no okay then listen maybe like chill out
we all got stuff on the skeletons in the
closet and we've all made mistakes kind
of relax and let's compete and see who's
going to get better and then if you got
a better argument i'd live more power to
you don't you don't trump try to start a
league nfl who's the one player he
picked up do you guys remember steve
young who else did he pick up the the
name that now was running for senator
christopher walker herschel walker
it was the biggest thing when trump
started a football league new jersey
generals and he went and brought
herschel walker and herschel walker said
no to the nfl but he said yes to trump
why because they paid better so it's
herschel walker's a guy that's for sale
and then he went there and he's like you
know what trump you failed i'm gonna go
to the nba and to the nfl and then so
this is not easy to do there's a lot of
xflowers out there people have tried aba
was out there julius irving used to be
part of aba before nba a bunch of guys
played for aba so we're going to find
out if they can compete here's the truth
it's going to take a lot more than money
to be able to compete against the pga a
lot more money yeah than that so we'll
see if they'll pull it off or not so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]